wir es mal Vorfall bei dieser
Wahlkampfveranstaltung ist ja nun
wirklich noch ganz vieles unklar
wir hören jetzt erstmal Tino kropaller
denn in diesem Moment ist er
eingetroffen bei der Pressekonferenz und
dann werden wir das was noch unklar ist
vielleicht mal ein bisschen genauer
benennen und beschreiben Katja Riedel
sie hören auch zu bis gleich jetzt
erstmal zur PK
live
ja schönen guten Tag meine Damen und
Herren zur Pressekonferenz der AFD
Fraktion mit unserem
Fraktionsvorsitzenden Tino kropaller zu
den Vorfällen in Ingolstadt bitte Herr
Kaller ja auch von meiner Seite herzlich
willkommen möchte auch
vorweg mich als
allererstes bei den vielen Zusendungen
der Genesungswünsche von letzte Woche
bedanken parteiübergreifend aber auch
natürlich viel aus der eigenen Partei
aus der zivilg Gesellschaft haben ich
viele aufmunternde Worte erreicht dafür
möchte ich mich hier herzlich bedanken
auch von Pressevertretern
das hat mir durchaus auch auf dem Weg
der Besserung geholfen ich möchte heute
den Tag nutzen gerade im im Bereich der
Berichterstattung der letzten Woche um
einige neue Fakten hier darzulegen ich
werde mich nicht an Spekulationen
beteiligen die es in alle Richtungen
durchaus gibt ich überlasse das absolut
was die Aufklärung angeht der Stad
stanwaltschaft und den Polizeibehörden
das war immer mein ansinn gewesen und
deshalb ist es mir auch heute erst
möglich auch aus gesundheitlichen Gründe
mich überhaupt dazu selbst zu äußern sie
wissen dass es einige Pressemitteilungen
meines Büros und auch der Partei gab
dahingehend wie es mir aktuell geht wie
der aktuelle Sachstand ist gleich wohl
wollte ich auch diesen Vorwurf der
eventuell dann auch in Raum stand und
stünde der teilweise auch von
politischen Gegner oder von Personen die
es nicht gut mit der AFD meinen äh
genutzt wurde dass wir das oder dass ich
das vor allem irgendeiner Weise
politisch nutzen wollte und möchte und
noch dazu in den Bezug zur Landtagswahl
deswegen
habe ich mich wie gesagt dazu bislang
auch nicht geäußert nun gibt es ja
Informationen pressetechnisch auch von
der Staatsanwaltschaft
die Information an die Presse gegeben
haben wir haben auch heute erst ein eine
Antwort zum ersten Mal von der
Staatsanwaltschaft auch dahingehend
bekommen die werde ich dann auch gleich
einblenden bzw ihn auch daraus zitier
die Bewertung und Beurteilung der
Aussagen überlasse ich Ihnen das ist ja
auch ihre journalistische äh Arbeit und
auch ihre Aufgabe das zu bewerten zu den
Vorkommnissen die sie ja zum Teil schon
wissen wie es ingerstadt auch abgelaufen
ist was auch in ingstadt schon bereits
festgestellt wurde schon am
Tatort nachdem ich
dort schwächemäßig mein Kreislauf
sozusagen versagt hat und ich dort im
schwi el und auch mit Brechreiz zu Boden
gegangen bin und das BKA mich dort auch
geschützt und gestützt hat wurde dort
vor Ort bereits ein blutfleg an meinem
rechten Arm festgestellt woraufhin auch
die BKA Leute der Polizei mitgeteilt
haben dass es sich hier wahrscheinlich
um einen Tatort handelt und dass hier
gewisse Maßnahmen eingeleitet werden
müssen was tatortsicherung angeht das
haben die BKA Leute auch der Polizei
gegenüber so geäußert auch das wurde im
Krankenwagen nachdem ich dann verbracht
wurde fest gestellt die Kleidung mein
Hemd mein mein Unterhemd und auch meine
Jacke wurde äh eingezogen von der
Polizei und befindet sich noch in der
Auswertung gerichtsmedizinisch bzw
forensisch da gibt's bislang keine
Ergebnisse dazu was im Krankenhaus und
auch schon bereits im Krankenwagen
festgestellt wurde dass es ein Einstich
oder einen eine Stich Verletzung am
rechten Oberarm festgestellt wurde das
wurde ja auch wie Sie wissen im
Krankenhaus
Abschlussbericht diagnostiziert und auch
so
festgeschrieben ich habe nachdem ich das
Krankenhaus am Donnerstag verlassen habe
am
Abend mich am Freitag nach Dresden
begeben in der städische Klinikum und
habe mir den gesamten Einstich entfernen
lassen und auch dort pathologisch
untersuchen lassen die pathologische
Auswertung des einstiches wir können es
gerne einblenden Herr
Schmidt wurde v und dort gibt es auch
ein
Ergebnis das ist jetzt den Bericht erstm
das ist das sind die Fotos mit den kan
man nicht VI fangen ach so dann z ja
korrekt richtig
den so in diesen Bericht ist klar
beschrieben was der Befund gebracht hat
dass sich
hierbei um einen
Einstich mindestens 4 mm tief handelt
das hier auch davon auszugehen ist und
klar ist dass es sich nicht um eine
Biene Wespe Mücke handelt wie ja
teilweise spekuliert wurde und dass die
beschriebene histologischen Befunde mit
einem Einstich mit einem Stichkanal
vereinbar sind auch das belegt dass es
dort zu einem Einstich gekommen
ist weitere pathologische Untersuchung
was auch dort mit Partikeln die im
Einstich gefunden wurden stehen noch aus
werden auch noch vor durchgeführt
genauso wie auch weitere Befunde der
Blutuntersuchungen noch ausstehen
teilweise wie Sie vielleicht wissen wie
ich mich jetzt selbst auch die letzten
Tage informiert habe besteht
wenn man Gifte nachweist oder bzw
überprüft teilweise dauert das Wochen
und man muss natürlich auch genau wissen
nach welchen Substanzen man sucht
Quecksilber das kann ich sagen wurde
nicht gefunden dieser Test ist bereits
durchgeführt worden also ist kein
queckselber nachgewiesen worden weil
diese Fragen gab es es ja
auch nichtsdestotrotz möchte ich noch
mal auch zur Staatsanwaltschaft kurz
Stellung beziehen die ja teilweise in
Presse Mitteilung und Nachrichten schon
ein anderes Bild dargestellt hat auch in
den Presseveröffentlichung die
stattfanden
wurde ja auch immer gesprochen nach
Angaben der AFD sie haben gesehen und
sehen jetzt mit beiden Angaben des
Arztbriefes der der des Klinikum
Ingolstadt genauso wie der Pathologie
Dresden dass es sich hier nicht um
Angaben der AFD handelt sondern dass es
unabhängig geprüft wurde von den
jeweiligen zuständigen Ärzten Pathologen
und auch morphologen die das klar sagen
die Staatsanwaltschaft hat mir wie
gesagt heute einen Brief geschickt Herr
Schmidt sie können gerne den ersten die
erste Seite
einblenden und die lässt schon eine
zweideutige Ausführung auch vermuten
weil hier wurde weil wir uns am Samstag
an die Staatsanwaltschaft mit einer
Abmahnung gewandt haben was die
Berichterstattung
angeht müsste der Brief sein haben Sie
den haben sie nicht gut dann kann ich
ihn vielleicht mal kurz zitieren dass
wir uns wie gesagt am Samstag haben wir
uns an die Staatsanwaltschaft mit einer
abmalnung gewandt was die
Berichterstattung angeht und vor allenen
was die Information an die Presse anging
sie hat heute geantwortet ich zitiere
vorab möchte ich Sie darauf hinweisen
dass gegen ihren Ausführungen die
Öffentlichkeit durch die
Staatsanwaltschaft Ingolstadt nicht
informiert wurde der fortlaufende Satz
auf Anfrage verschiedener
Pressevertreter wurden den betreffenden
Journalisten Auskünfte zum
gegenständlichen Ermittlungsverfahren
erteilt also ganz ehrlich wer das
geschrieben hat der versteht
wahrscheinlich seine eigenen Worte nicht
also man hat Auskünfte gegeben im ersten
Satz hat man es negiert das sind die
Antworten der Staatsanwaltschaft also
daran sieht man dass hier teilweise
auskünft die gegeben wurden genauso hier
ich zitiere weiter anders als von ihnen
dargestellt wurde das Ergebnis der
Blutuntersuchung keineswegs an die
Presse
mitgeteilt viel mehr wurde berichtet im
nachfolgenden Satz dass das Ergebnis bis
auf eine Schmerzmedikation im
therapeutischen Bereich negativ
verlaufen ist also man hat doch Dinge
mitgeteilt z.B was Werte meines Blutes
anging die ich abends oder die meine
Familie abends in der tagesschow dann
entnehmen konnte und ich war immer
eigentlich der Meinung dass es in
Deutschland noch die ärztliche
Schweigepflicht gibt ich habe auch keine
Ärzte im Klinikum Ingolstadt von der
ärztlichen Schweigepflicht befreit
dennoch wurden wahrscheinlich Aussag
getätigt es gibt ja auch Berichte dass
der Arzt verhört wurde das kann ich
nicht bestätigen das weiß ich nicht das
wäre vielleicht Aufgabe auch von Ihnen
das zu überprüfen ich möchte mich da wie
gesagt nicht an Spekulation beteiligen
insgesamt ist dieser Angriff auf mich
als Anschlag zu
werden für uns und auch für mich ist ist
dahingehend wichtig dass wir diese und
DAU bin ich gerne bereit auch diese
Unterlagen natürlich der
Staatsanwaltschaft zur Verfügung zu
stellen zur Aufklärung beizutragen weil
hier geht es nicht nur um die Person
Tino kopalla hier geht es für mich um
vielleicht eine Qualität wie Politiker
in diesem Land angegriffen werden egal
welcher Partei das will ich ganz klar
sagen auch was Veranstaltungen angeht im
öffentlichen Bereich wo auch wir uns als
Partei natürlich in Zukunft die Frage
stellen wie wir sie noch durchführen
können in welchen Sicherheitsbereich wir
Sie durchführen können
und ob wir sie in Zukunft zu durchführen
können insgesamt muss ich sagen auch das
vielleicht dazu ist zu erwähnen dass
auch mir dort die Situation in
Ingolstadt
insgesamt schwierig vorkam was die
Veranstaltung angeht was die
Veranstaltung Organisation angeht auch
der der zugelassenen Demonstration die
AFD Veranstaltung auf dem Platz in
Ingolstadt war mittig gelagert und auch
dort zugelassen links eingekesselt war
eine Veranstaltung der sogenannten
Zivilgesellschaft mit dem
Oberbürgermeister mit anderen Vertretern
auch andere Parteien wie dem freien
wähln rechts von dieser AFD
Veranstaltung waren war die antifah
positioniert also auch das sind Dinge
die man in Zukunft wirklich was die
Entfernung auch dieser dieser
Veranstaltung angeht wirklich genauer
prüfen sollte ob man sowas überhaupt
noch zulässt ist die zweite Frage gerade
aus sicherheitsrelevanten
Bereichen
wie gesagt aktuell noch mal zu den zu
den Fakten die bislang wie gesagt
feststellbar sind es ist der Blutfleck
der klar diagnostiziert und festgestellt
wurde das ist der Einstich durch was
auch immer eine nadelkanüle bzw das ist
pathologisch bestätigt worden dass es
sich um sowas gehandelt wurde bislang
wurden keine weiteren Substanzen
gefunden das besteht und ist doch weiter
in Prüfung
das sind die aktuellen Fakten zu meinem
Gesundheitszustand muss ich sagen äh ich
habe das gestern schon gemerkt als mein
erster Tag sozusagen hier auch in der
Fraktion zur Fraktionswahl Anstand dass
ich mich kräftemäßig bei 70% sehe dass
es mir früh noch sehr übel geht dass ich
unter Appetitlosigkeit leide und dass
ich dennoch hoffe mich auf einen guten
Weg der Besserung zu befinden so viel
vielleicht von meiner Seite zum Anfang
vielen
Dank so schm sie machen die Rednerliste
gut gibt es Fragen ja tatsächlich bitte
fangen wir hier
an wollen das Mikrofon vielleicht
benutzen dann HST oder hören wir alles
besser Entschuldigung ir seam aus dem a
hauptstattstudio herzlichen Dank für
diese Information ich habe es vielleicht
ist es an mir vorbeigerauscht vielleicht
könnten sie noch mal ganz kurz sagen wer
diesen Brief erstellt hat diesen
ärztlichen Brief und vielleicht könnten
sie auch noch was dazu sagen wie es denn
dazu gekommen ist dass die Mitteilungen
da auch etwas unterschiedlich waren was
auch die Situation von Frau Weidel
angegangen ist und wenn sie mir erlauben
ein Thema zum Stiftungsgesetz würden sie
dazu vielleicht auch noch etwas sagen
gut zur Stiftung würde ich heute
vielleicht nichts sagen ist vielleicht
ein bisschen unpassend
die Ärzte oder die der Bericht den kann
ich Ihnen gerne wie gesagt auch zukommen
lassen das sind die Ärzte auch klar
benannt also es ist jetzt kein Geheimnis
es ist der die die Bericht auch
geschaffen haben es ist Frau Dr Jakob
und auch Oberärztin Frau Dr schönlebe
also sind mit mit
ach aus dem Krankenhaus aus dem
Krankenhaus das ist ein and die mein aus
dem Krankenhaus ingostadt das
sind andere Ärzte in der Tat die den
erztbericht auch geschrieben haben das
ist Dr me Blerim luani und dr me Peter
Reil Stefan Zimmer ist als Assistenzarzt
noch hiermit genannt die den Brief mit
verfasst bzw die unter diesem Brief der
Entlassung stehen die zweite Frage ach
so mit ja ich meine die
Berichterstattung mit Frau wurde
natürlich in den Kontext sicherlich
zusammengefasst stehen aber in keinen
Zusammenhang zumindestens was wir
aktuell wissen also von daher kann ich
dazu jetzt
keine Auskunft
geben
dann ja J Rats dpa hrupaller könnten Sie
vielleicht noch mal den Moment schildern
weil das ist ein bisschen unklar da
gab's von der Staatsanwaltschaft die
Aussage habe einen engen Körperkontakt
gegeben beim selfies machen und sie
hätten auch ausgesagt dann da aber nicht
irgendwie ein Angriff oder irgendwas
gespürt zu haben können Sie das noch mal
schildern wie das aus ihrer Sicht lief
mache ich gerne ich habe wie gesagt das
geschildert was ich wahrgenommen habe
auch wahrheitsgemäß um auch wie gesagt
ich habe auch keine Verdächtigung in der
Weise auch ausgesprochen das ist genauso
habe ich auch meine Zeugenaussage der
Polizei gegenüber genannt ich bin aus
dem Wagen ausgestiegen habe wurde dort
relativ
zeitnah von mehreren Leuten umringt bzw
begrüßt auch begrüßt von eigenen
Parteifreunden von Frau bner Steiner von
Herrn Grosch aus Österreich und auch von
Herrn Böhm dann kam es zu selfie und
Autogrammwünschen relativ zeitnah wie
gesagt nach ausstieg und auch zu
weiteren Begegnungen mit mit jungen
Menschen ich habe in dieser Situation
auch mit Umarmungen also auch mit
selfies wo der Arm um die Schulter
gelegt wurde nichts festgestellt das ist
habe ich auch immer wieder ausgesagt ich
habe auch kein Einstich festgestellt in
diesem Moment ich bin danach vom
zeitlichen ablauflach ungefähr 7 8
Minuten zur Bühne gegangen und habe dann
gemerkt wie mein rechter Arm bis zum
Ellenbogen hart wurde und schmerzte und
daraufhin habe ich auch ein ein ein
Einstich festgestellt oder bzw verspürt
der der untypisch war ich meinen mein
armschmerz oder ein Muskelschmerz kann
durchaus irgendwo mal vorkommen aber es
war untypisch und danach wurde mir auch
relativ schnell schwindlig und
hatte auch einen Brechreiz bzw äh starke
Kopfschmerzen woraufhin ich mich an
meinen bürroleiter wandte der mich mit
dem BKA dann zurück hinter die Bühne
gebracht hat und das andere kennen sie
wo ich mich hinsetzte und ja auch dort
ich sag's mal so in einem nicht
abgesicherten Bereich und das ist das
was ich als sicherheitsrelevant schon
auch für uns sehe was in Zukunft anders
sein muss dort erstmal wartete bzw dann
in den BKA Auto verbracht wurde vorab
wie gesagt wurde mir die Jacke
ausgezogen und dort hat man die
Einstiegsstelle auch
festgestellt Herr
schintler Herr preus ich noch gerne also
wir haben jetzt nehmen Sie Mikro ja wir
haben jetzt immer noch unterschiedliche
Darstellungen sie haben gesagt da war
eindeutigen Einstich da war ein
Blutfleck
wenn wir bekommen von der
Staatsanwaltschaft ja wiederholt die
Auskunft wir können das nicht bestätigen
also wir können kein vom Blutfleck war
nicht die Rede es ist die es war davon
die Rede wir haben eine Rötung
festgestellt
aber kein Einstich wie erklären Sie sich
diese unterschiedlich die Darstellung
auch jetzt sozusagen von dem was sie von
den BKA Beamten erzählt haben dass die
das auch gleich festgestellt hatten
bekommen wir ja keine Bestätigung von
den Ermittlern sondern dort heißt es wir
können diese Version nicht bestätigen
wie erklären Sie sich das die haben ja
auch mit den AR Ärzten geredet wie sie
ja auch bestätigt haben das weiß ich
nicht ob sie mit den Ärzten geredet
haben das wie gesagt und G her Prus aber
sie haben Bezug genommen genau also auch
die toxikologische Untersuchung da sind
sich ja noch weitgehend einig dass sie
sagen wir können hier nichts bestätigen
außer die Schmerzmittel wie wie erklären
Sie sich diese unterschiedliche
Darstellung dass es dort keinerlei
Bestätigung von der zuständigen
Ermittlungsbehörde gibt Wien sie bin ich
jetzt genau in den Bereich der
Vermutungen und in dem begebe ich mich
nicht ich habe ihn heute und meine
Sichtweise meine Fakten genannt und das
sind Fakten und die Aussagen auch der
BKA Leute was den blutfleg angeht sind
aufgenommen worden bei der Polizei warum
die Staatsanwaltschaft Z reagiert das
müssen sie die staatsanwal
Staatsanwaltschaft auch Fragen das kann
ich nicht bewerten und beurteilen das
weiß ich nicht und die Fr Frage ist ja
warum wurde denn meine Kleidung auch
konfisiert und bzw eingezogen und weiter
untersucht wenn dort kein Blutfleck war
muss man meiner Meinung nach die
Kleidung auch nicht einziehen und
behalten also von daher ist genau das
auch getan wurde im Krankenhaus im
Übrigen wurde einer einstistelle eine
dnapre gemacht und entnommen von der
Polizei und ich meine das ist Aufgabe
der
Ermittlungsbehörden und auch der
Staatsanwaltschaft warum die
Staatsanwaltschaft das sagt oder so sagt
warum sie sich überhaupt äußert zu
Dingen die die aktuell noch nicht
feststehen oder wo Ermittlung noch offen
sind die Frage kann ich nicht
beantworten ich finde es ein Stück weit
wirklich ein Skandal sag ich ganz
ehrlich dass man sich als Opfer in eine
Rechtfertigung begeben muss weil falsch
informformation oder Weglassen von
Informationen in der öffentlichen in den
öffentlichen Aussagen zum Standard
geworden sind ich frage mich
wirklich wie würden sie das bezeichnen
oder was hätte hätten wie hätten die
Medien reagiert wäre eine andere Person
einer anderen Partei genauso mit diesem
Vorfall bedacht gewesen also was ich ich
muss mich wirklich ein bisschen wundern
weil ich habe mich explizit und das war
immer mein ansinn zurückgehalten in
Vorverurteilung in Bewertungen ich werde
mich auch jetzt nicht an Spekulation
beteiligen weil ich auch die
Ermittlungsergebnisse abwarten möchte
was ich aber jetzt natürlich wo ich mich
gezwungen sehe mich zurecht fertigen
weil natürlich Gerüchte kommen oder
gesagt wird da war nichts oder den
kopalla ging's vorher schon nicht gut im
übrigen ich bin sehr ausgeruht und fit
wie ich immer bin nach Ingolstadt
gefahren ich hatte die den Mittwoch war
für mich der Start von fünf weiteren
Veranstaltungen bis Samstag bzw auch mit
dem Wahlabend am Sonntag in München im
im Landtag das war mein Plan gewesen um
am Montag früh nach Berlin zu reisen und
an der Bundespressekonferenz
teilzunehmen also von daher war ich gut
vorbereitet ich war gesund und ich
fühlte mich
fit dazu genau weil sie gesagt
habenentschuldigung nur kurze Nachfrage
weil sie ja gesagt haben sie überlassen
das jetzt den Ermittlern und der
Staatsanwaltschaft aber offenbar sind
sie ja nicht zufrieden mit den wie wie
wie das ganze läuft sonst würden sie ja
nicht heute sozusagen ihre een
ermittlungser ich hab ja ich habe ihn ja
den Brief der Staatsanwaltschaft
übermittelt ich meine sie fing an zu
erzählen es gäbe
nichts das ist einfach falsch ich
meine
wenn ich bin in
Ingolstadt
mit diesen mit diesen Angriff Vorfall
wie auch immer man das erstmal bewerten
will aber für mich ist es ein Angriff
nachdem ich den pathologische Auswertung
haben wie kommen denn der Stich dorthin
wie kommt denn der Blutfleck dorthin das
kann man ja nicht negieren das sind
Fakten warum die Staatsanwaltschaft das
anders sieht das müssen sie wie gesagt
die staatsanwalschaft
Fragen
Kollege Herr kopaller zwei Fragen einmal
seit wann reden sie oder seit wann
wissen sie von dem Blutfleck und die
zweite Frage wäre noch sie haben gesagt
sie wollen sich an Spekulationen nicht
beteiligen jetzt haben sie mehrfach
schon auf die
Gegendemonstrationen von Antifaschisten
hingewiesen und da wäre jetzt meine
Frage ist das nicht ihrer Meinung nach
auch eine Schlussfolgerung die sie da
ziehen wenn sie sagen dass sowas in
Zukunft nicht mehr stattfinden sollte
sehen Sie da ein Zusammenhang zwischen
der Demonstration und dem Einstich was
war noch mal die erste Frage seit wann
sie von dem Blutfleck
reden na ich ich meine ich habe ich die
ersten Tage nicht in der Lage gesehen
überhaupt zu reden der Blutfleck wurde
am Mittwoch bereits festgestellt in
ingerstadt auf dem Platz so und das ist
bestätigt von drei PKA Leuten die das
auch der Polizei ausgesagt
haben ich habe keine Spekulation
dahingingen was die Täter oder Täter
sein könnten hier getroffen ich habe
berichtet wie die Lage vor Ort war mit
den
Gegendemonstration jetzt also ich habe
nicht spekuliert dass es von
kommt kam käme das weiß ich nicht und
habe ich auch immer so ausgesagt
deswegen habe ich auch gesagt ich habe
nichts bemerkt ja und ich habe auch
keine Person die Personen mit denen ich
selfies gemacht haben waren alle
sympathisch und waren alle nett es hat
niemand in irgendeiner Weise ein
Anschein gebracht und gemacht als wenn
er mir was Böses antun wollte das ist
hätten auch die BKA Leute die mich an
dem Tag begleitet haben sicher auch
bemerkt also von daher kann ich das und
das so habe ich es auch ausgesagt und
das ist sicherlich die Aussage auf die
sich die Staatsanwaltschaft stüzt K hat
gesagt es war nichts ja ich habe nichts
mit festgestellt bis ich am Boden lag
und der Blutfleck festgestellt
wurde zur Staatsanwaltschaft kann auch
angemerkt werden dass sie natürlich
unterstützt wird und die Befunde auch
zur Verfügung korrekt gestellt
werden Herr kaler zwei Fragen Nicole
dimann ZDF erste Frage ist noch mal
warum genau sind sie da noch mal in
Dresden ins Krankenhaus gegangen und
zweite Frage der Arztbrief ist ja letzte
Woche auch an die Öffentlichkeit gelangt
warum fehlt da der
diagnoseteil der fehlt nicht Seite 1 ist
ganz klar aufgelisse
Diagnosen es fehlt Seite 3 den kann ich
ihnen geben das ist eigentlich nur noch
der der letzte kleine Absatz das sind
drei Sätze aber die können Sie gerne
bekommen okay und sagen Sie mir noch
warum sie da noch mal in Dresden ins
Krankenhaus gegangen sind für mich war
es dahin gehen auch mit Beratung vieler
Ärzte auch mit
dankensweiterweise vielen Informationen
von Ärzten die mich auch kontaktiert hab
wichtig und ich freue mich auch darüber
ich sage ihn auch rein von meinen
persönlichen Empfinden war es mir
wichtig diesen Einstich der sich auch
hart anfühlte der äh für mich in auch in
Unwohlsein und psychisches Unwohlsein
bedeutet einfach zu entfernen und ich
bin no froh dass ich das getan habe noch
dazu wo sich ja auch und das ist ja auch
im pathologischen Bericht klar definiert
worden festgestellt wurde dass es hier
zu einem Entzündungsinfiltrat das
gefunden wurde und dass man auch
dahahingehend das seitfenster genauer
definieren kann also von daher war mir
das wichtig und ich fühle mich einfach
auf psychisch wohler dass genau das aus
meinem Arm verschwunden ist eine
Nachfrage warum haben sie das dann nicht
auch in Ingolstadt machen lassen ich
habe gestern Abend mit zwei Ärzten
gesprochen die sagen je mehr Zeit
verstreicht desto schwieriger wird es
auch im geebe was nachzuweisen deswegen
haben sie dadurch dass sie nach Dresen
gegangen sind ja auch noch mal wertvolle
Zeit verloren na ja zu der Zeitachse
gibt's verschiedene Aussagen also die
Pathologen mit denen ich geredet haben
gesagt man kann sehr wohl 14 Tage selbst
14 Tage nach einem einsti noch ein
einsti feststellen nach Gewebeproben
Kontrollen
das ist eine Frage die man auch dem
Krankenhaus ingorstadt sicherlich
stellen müsste warum
weil ich es war sichtbar es wurde ein
DNA
ab Strich auch am Einstich vorgenommen
warum man das nicht pathologisch
untersuchen lass hat hat lassen diese
Diskussion gab ist das habe ich
mitbekommen aber man hat sich dagegen
entschieden warum kann ich nicht
bewerten ich bin ich bin kein Arzt ich
fange jetzt nicht an zu sagen was die
Ärzte zu tun und zu lassen und zu machen
haben das ist Aufgabe von den Ärzten ich
will aber gleich wohl auch sagen dass
ich mich insgesamt in Ingolstadt gut
aufgehoben gefühlt habe und ich mich
auch beim Klinikum Ingolstadt bedanken
möchte für die vorzügliche auch schnelle
ärztliche Versorgung das ist keine
Kritik was die Versorgung angeht
auch hier ich habe ja auch im
Krankenhaus Ingolstadt mehr Blutproben
mindestens drei an an das Krankenhaus
abgegeben auch an die Polizei und auch
an die Gerichtsmedizin also es gab
mehrere Blutproben die ich dort
abgegeben habe und ich habe auch im nach
im
Nachgang selbst private Blutproben
entnommen und die auch an private Labore
gegeben um auch hier Sicherheit zu
erlangen und auch die selbst zu prüfen
und auch diese Ergebnisse alle
Ergebnisse dieser Untersuchung und
Proben genauso wie die pathologische
Untersuchung gebe ich natürlich gerar
der Staatsanwaltschaft auch zur
Verfügung mein Interesse ist es dass es
aufgeklärt wird und natürlich ist es
auch für mich vom großen Interesse was
äh in meinen Körper gelangen sein kann
oder könnte es gibt Tests wie gesagt die
kann man auch erst in 3 vi Wochen
durchführen weil man erst dann im Blut
nachweisen kann um was es für Substanzen
es sich handelt um welche Infektionen es
sich handelt äh es kann ja auch eine
eine eine verschmutzte oder sonstige
Nadel gewesen sein wo man nicht weiß was
konkret an dieser Nadel dran sein muss
also von daher sind das Dinge die ich
für mich noch verarbeite auch ganz
ehrlich auch psychisch verarbeiten muss
und deswegen war es mir wichtig alles zu
unternehmen und mir auch den zween
dritten ärztlichen Rat
einzuholen Frederike Haupt von der fazz
danke schon mal Herr krupaler ich habe
drei Detailfragen die mögen Ihnen
vielleicht kleinkariert vorkommen aber
ich versuche möglichst genau zu
verstehen was ihnen passiert ist und was
das zu bedeuten hat die erste ist sie
haben uns gerade den Zusatzbericht
gezeigt da würde mich interessieren ob
das also zu was das der Zusatz ist und
was in dem möglicherweise noch
nicht gezeigten weiteren Dokument
steht das zweite ist sie hatten eingangs
gesagt sie seien zu Boden gegangen eben
haben sie dann aber einen einen Ablauf
geschildert indem sie sich hingesetzt
haben nachdem sie erst 7 bis 8 Minuten
nichts gemerkt hätten also sind sie zu
Boden gestürzt oder mussten sie sich
setzen weil sie
sich sehr schwach fühlten und das dritte
ist gestern sprach die bayerische
spitzenkandidaen von einem gescheiterten
Attentat auf sie würden sie sich auch
dieser Deutung anschließen und wenn ja
das Attentat also gescheitert ist was
vermuten sie oder was wissen sie darüber
was die eigentliche Absicht des
Attentats gewesen
ist zur ersten Frage äh es gibt
natürlich immer einen Vorbericht den ich
an
Vorabend
am monondtag bekommen habe und der
Zusatzbericht bestätigt im Prinzip den
Vorbericht das ist der Abschlussbericht
sozusagen der Pathologie zweotens ich
bin ich zu Boden gestürzt ich habe wie
gesagt ich habe mich habe unter
Schwindel geleidet unter starken
Kopfschmerzen unter Unwohlsein und habe
mich hingekniet bzw mein Mitarbeiter hat
mich begleitet mit dem BKA um mich
hinzusetzen um nicht zu stürzen es ist
ja auch nicht schön ich sag's ihn ganz
offen wenn man
auch dem einen einen würge und Brechreiz
vernimmt an einer stark befahrenen
Straße Minuten lang im Dreck liegt da
macht man sich natürlich auch Gedanken
welche Bilder entstehen könnten das ist
durch geht in durchaus Kopf und solches
solche
Dinge nimmt man in diesem Moment wahr
von daher war es gut dass man sich
hingesetzt od ich mich hingesetzt habe
dass ich auch umringt wurde um genau
diese Bildmaterialien zu vermeiden Frau
Ebner Steiner hat vom Anschlag
gesprochen ich würde ne vom Attentat
gesprochen ich würde von Anschlag
durchaussprechen die Gegenfrage müsste
ich ja mal an Sie stellen wie würden sie
es denn bezeichnen wenn Sie jetzt die
Fakten sehen oder wie würden sie es
bezeichnen wenn es einer anderen Person
einer anderen Partei genauso ergangen
ist mir ging es jetzt vor allem auch um
das Attribut gescheitert das für mich
impliziert dass Frau Ebner steinerne
Kenntnis hat über die Absicht des
mutmaßlichen Anschlags oder Attentat das
wird sie sicherlich nicht haben die
Kenntnis die habe ich ja selbst nicht ob
er gescheitert ist das wissen wir ja
noch nicht mal und
ich verstehe aber jede und es gibt ja
viele Äußerungen ja auch sicherlich
emotional vielleicht auch über das Ziel
hinausschießende Äußerung von eigenen
Partei funktionieren das will ich
überhaupt nicht negieren aber Sie müssen
sich vorstellen was es auch gerade im
Abschluss einer eines Wahlkampfes mit
den Personen ausmacht äh und wie es den
Personen eigentlich damit auch geht wo
man vielleicht nicht W man bis heute
nicht weiß was ist eigentlich
vorgefallen und kann es auch andere
Personen treffen das habe ich ja
eingangs auch gesagt was die
Sicherheitsrelevanz angeht auch für
unsere Partei auch für Veranstaltung
vielleicht sind wir mit vielen Dingen
und das ist auch ein Stück weit ekritik
in den letzten Monaten Tagen Jahren zu
leichtsinnig umgegangen und vielleicht
haben wir eine andere Situation auch in
Deutschland was die Sicherheitslage
angeht das betrifft nicht nur die AFD
obwohl wir natürlich mit diejenigen sind
die am meisten angegriffen wden und ich
wenn ich jetzt mal äh die Genese meiner
eigenen Person sehe und die Auflistung
gehe von privaten Angriffen von
Beschmierungen meines Wohnhauses xmal
vom Anschlag auf meinen Familienauto zu
Hause was abgebrannt wurde ja von
Beschmierungen von Bürotüren im
Bundestag der Vorsitzenden von
Beschmierungen der Autos im Bundestag
von den Vorsitzenden was nicht
aufgeklärt wurde wo man sich meint und
denkt selbst im Bundestag kann man nicht
sicher sein da müssen sie mal verstehen
was in den Personen in den Menschen
vorgeht und wie man sich selbst fühlt wo
kann man eigentlich noch frei öffentlich
in diesem Land
äh auftreten ohne permanent die Angst
die Gefahr zu spüren dass heute was
passieren könnte und das finde ich schon
ein Stück weit relevant und
wie gesagt hier geht's nicht um meine
Person im im im Vordergrund hier geht's
für mich um die Sicherheit auch der
gesamten Politiker unserer Partei aber
auch aller
anderen gut wir müssen ein bisschen auf
die Zeit achten deshalb bitte kurze
Fragen Kollege Herr kupaler cllemen
Justus weltfernsehen könnten Sie bitte
noch mal kurz die tatsächlichen
medizinischen Neuigkeiten
zusammenfassen gut die medizinischen
Neuigkeiten was haben sie haben den
pathologiebericht das sind die
medizinischen Neuigkeiten bislang wie
gesagt das habe ich ja schon erwähnt
wurden in den blutprom keine Substanzen
festgestellt ist das was ich an den
aktuellen nach der nach den aktuellen
Substanzen wie z.B Quecksilber gesucht
wurde aber sie wissen das habe ich auch
schon mal gesagt es ist nicht so dass
man das Blut kontrolliert und dann kommt
raus dass das dass das ist im im Blut
oder könnte enthalten sein man muss
konkret wissen nach was man sucht um
überhaupt festzustellen ob es im Blut
vorhanden ist ob es ein ein tiergift ist
ein Schlangengift etc es gibt ja
mittlerweile so viele Varianten wie
gesagt ich bin mittlerweile selbst habe
mich da selbst informieren und belesen
müssen kannte mich mit solchen Sachen
nicht aus bin auch kein Arzt kurze
Nachfrage nach was wird denn genau
gesucht
sie haben doch mit Sicherheit Auskunft
darüber nach was jetzt in ihrem Blut
gesucht allen möglichen Substanzen
Quecksilber no wieock ist sicherlich
auch dabei also auch diese Dinge werden
untersucht noch mal wir können nicht
ausschließen von welchen Personen oder
von ja auch Diensten hier eventuell was
vorgenommen wurde Herr
fin vol Deutsch wenn ich Ihren
Ausführung Folge steht jetzt ganz nicht
betrachtet Aussage gegen Aussage und
mich würde des interessieren wie sie
jetzt weiter vorgehen wollen sie haben
jetzt Meinung von Dritten Instituten
eingeholt wollen sie jetzt juristisch
gegen die Staatsanwaltschaft in
Ingolstadt vorgehen damit es zu eine
Klärung kommt oder reicht es Ihnen die
Information zur Verfügung zu stellen
damit dort das vor Ort geklärt wird ja
gut ich bin ja wir sind ja im im
juristischen Kontakt mit der
Staatsanwaltschaft wie ich Ihnen gesagt
hat dass wir da wir am Samstag bereits
die Unterlassung auch der
Staatsanwaltschaft zukommen lassen haben
ich überlasse alle Ergebnisse und
Unterlagen der Staatsanwaltschaft und
hoffe natürlich auch im Gegenzug s ich
auch ganz deutlich auf Information z.B
auch meiner Kleidung dass ich diese
Information als Geschädigter als Opfer
zuerst erhalte ich denke das hat ein
Stück weit was mit PT zu tun mit Anstand
diese Zusammenarbeit die wünsche ich mir
und wenn die Staatsanwaltschaft trotz
ihrer Erläuterungen an ihrer
Einschätzung oder an ihrer Bewertung
festhalten sollte ne das ist eine
bewertungssache ich meine wir haben es
ja richtig gesagt wenn Aussage gegen
Aussage steht
äh was soll ich da juristisch klären
lassen also ich denke wir werden die
nächsten Tage und Wochen vielleicht noch
weitere Ergebnisse bekommen ich hoffe es
und dann gilt es das sicherlich auch neu
zu bewerten Herr sch Herr kropaller laut
vorläufigem Arztbrief wurde bei ihnen
Ingolstadt ja auch ein sogenannter
kompletter
Rechtsschenkelblock festgestellt also
eine Störung der Erregungsleitung im
Herzen wurde ihnen da von den Ärzten
mitgeteilt ob es da einen Zusammenhang
geben könnte zu diesem Einstich bzw was
wurde ihnen zu diesem
Rechtsschenkelblock zu der ja
verschiedene Ursachen haben kann was
wurde ihnen da von den Ärzten mitgeteilt
genau das ist auch noch Klärung und
Prüfung deswegen habe ich das jetzt auch
nicht erwähnt ob es in in diesen in
Zusammenhang über die ein kurzfristiges
ein kurzfristiger Schaden vorhanden ist
oder ob der schon vorher vorhanden sein
kann durchaus durchaus möglich also das
ist noch wie gesagt in medizinische
Abklärung das lasse ich auch noch
aktuell hausärztlich weiter untersuchen
aber auch durch andere
Ärzte ja anschließend daran ähm sie
haben ja auch noch mal gesagt dass sie
sich an dem Tag fit gefühlt haben wurde
denn bei dieser ärztlichen Untersuchung
zum Einen oder auch bei der
polizeilichen Befragung irgendwie nach
dem
Ausschlussprinzip vorgegangen dass man
also sagt
wir wissen jetzt nicht genau was
daavorgefallen ist aber wir können sagen
wir mal ausschließen sie haben morgens
ein warmes Fischbrötchen oder alte
Mayonnaise oder sowas gegessen oder
irgendwie solche Sachen wäre ja auch
eine Methode und das zweite sind ihn
noch mal information zugegangen
bezüglich da war die Rede einmal von so
einer pinnwandnadel die gefunden wurde
und von zwei möglichen Personen die man
deren Personalien da festgestellt wurden
also natürlich wurde ich äh gefragt was
ich an dem Tag gegessen habe was ich
vorher gegessen habe es kann ich ih noch
sagen das habe ich auch so ausgesagt
dass es ein Apfel war den ich z Stunden
vorher gegessen habe im Auto weil ich
war ja auf direkter Anreise zu
ingerstatt wie gesagt ich habe mich
nicht unwohl gefühlt ich war gut
vorbereitet ich war fit habe mich auf
die Tage gefreut habe mich auf das äh
auf im Wahlkampfabschluss auch am
Sonntag in München gefreut die Leute
waren ä äh begeistert und haben sich auf
die Veranstaltung gefreut also von daher
das ist alles genannt worden es wurde
auch alles abgefragt
ähm was die Personen angeht das war die
zweite Frage ne ähm wie gesagt die
Personalien aller Personen wurden
aufgenommen es wurden alle auch befragt
und vernommen ist mein Kenntnisstand
über die Ergebnisse da darüber weiß ich
nichts und das gilt's auch
abzuwarten gut ich kann jetzt noch eine
Frage Steppen ja ich habe jetzt noch
nichts gehört zu dieser Frage Injektion
acho die die in die Nadel wollten sie
noch wissen ganz kurz vielleicht dazu es
wurde eine pinwandnadel entdeckt das
Foto habe ich auch gesehen ich weiß
nicht ob das mir polizeiamter gezeigt
hat auf dem Handy Fotos habe ich jetzt
so nicht gesehen ist korrekt auch die
wurde wie gesagt eingezogen und wird
noch überprüft also da liegen mir auch
keine Ergebnisse zu ob das das
Tatwerkzeug sein kann aber wenn man
jetzt den pathologischen Bericht sieht
auch von der Tiefe spricht es eigentlich
dagegen und ich denke Stich mit so einer
Nadel hätte hätte ich wahrscheinlich
auch
gespürt ich habe jetzt noch nichts
gehört zu dieser Frage Injektion und
toxische Substanz also laut
Staatsanwaltschaft ist ja an im
anamneseteil des ersten Arztbriefes die
Rede von Spritze in den mit Spritze in
den rechten Oberarm gestochen mit
Spritze und in dem Presse öffentlich
gewordenen Teil ist von einer
intramuskulären Injektion mit unklarer
Substanz Rede das finde ich jetzt hier
nach meinem leinhaften Verständnis nicht
wieder und ich würde mal interessieren
wie es zu diesen Niederschriften kam
haben die einfach das niedergeschrieben
was was sie ihnen dort erzählt haben
ihre Vermutung und Befürchtung oder wie
kommt es dazu letztlich dass diese
dieser Teil der Information heute
überhaupt gar keine Rolle spielt s
Einstich reden ja also her Ste mus man
vielleicht unterscheiden wir haben ja
hier den Bericht der Pathologie
eingeblendet und nicht den Arztbrief
oder den Entlassungsbrief aus dem
Krankenhaus ingelstadt wo genau das
erwähnt wurde was sie gerade gesagt
haben und ich kann ja mal draus zitieren
hier ist klar beschrieben körperlicher
Untersuchungsbefund und den körperlichen
Untersuchungsbefund muss ein Arzt
vornehmen die kann ich ja nicht selbst
vornehmen sonst brauch ich ja nicht ins
Krankenhaus gehen wenn ich dem Arzt sage
jetzt schreiben Sie mal bitte in den
Befund hinein
äh dies und jenes also Entschuldigung
was ist das für eine ärztliche
sorugepflicht körperlicher
Untersuchungsbefund hier wurde klar
festgestellt nach absuchen
aller der gesamten des gesamten Körpers
unter dem Punkt Extremitäten keine
Beinödeme Nadelstich rechter Oberarm im
Bereich m
Deltoideus das steht als Befund im
ärztebrief für mich gibt's da keine zwei
Fragen und in der Epikrise wird erwähnt
der intramuskuläre die intramuskuläre
Injektion mit einer unklaren substananz
zur weiteren Überwachung und so weiter
und so weiter das steht in dem Arztbrief
drin das sind nicht Schilderung die ich
gemacht habe weil ganz ehrlich ich bin
medizinch nicht nicht so bewandert um
solche Äußerung dem Arzt ins Heft zu
diktieren ja nachf soweit die
Pressekonferenz von Tino kopaller an der
Stelle machen wir jetzt mal einen Punkt
und fragen nach bei Katja Riedel
investigativjournalistin vom WDR wir
haben uns eben schon mal kurz begrüßt
Frau Riedel ich sehe nicht so richtig
weil uns Tina kopaller Tino kopaller
dann mit der Live Pressekonferenz
dazwischen gekommen ist also erstmal ein
herzliches hallo hallo also
wir haben jetzt
jede Menge Details gehört auch
Begrifflichkeiten von Tino kropalla m
auch eine Sache die ich zumindest hier
von dieser Stelle schon mal richtig
stellen möchte er hat gesagt die AFD
wird am häufigsten angegriffen ähm wir
haben uns dazu mal die Zahlen besorgt
Anschläge auf Politiker erste
Jahreshälfte
2023 wir sprechen hier möglicherweise
von einem Anschlag das ist noch nicht
bewiesen aber ähm einfach mal zu dem
Hintergrund da sind ganz vorne mit dabei
die Grünen mit 301 dann folgt die SPD
mit 153 und auf Platz 3 folgt dann die
AFD mit
121 Anschlägen die sozusagen notiert
sind in der ersten Jahreshälfte 2023
also ja AFD steht damit Nichten an der
Spitze das kann ich beitragen an dieser
Stelle und jetzt sind Sie dran wie hat
diese Pressekonferenz auf sie gewi wirkt
Frau
rel also ich habe nicht sehr viel Neues
erfahren muss ich ehrlich gestehen ich
habe erfahren dass es offenbar einen
Blutfleck gegeben hat und dass ich damit
auch die Indizien dass es tatsächlich
ein Stich möglich am Oberarm von
hernkoaller gegeben hat das hat sich für
mich erhärtet
nicht erhärtet hat sich für mich
bzw es ist für mich überhaupt nicht
nachprüfbar was in diesem zusätzlichen
dresner Gutachten stehen soll wo man
sich diese Stichstelle angeschaut hat
Herr kopaller hatte das ja sehr kurz
einblenden lassen ich konnte es so
schnell nicht lesen das müsste man
überprüfen
zumal er daraus
eben die Konsequenz zog es wäre jetzt
ausgeschlossen geschlossen dass es etwa
ein Insektenstich oder ähnliches sein
könnte das bin ich nicht in der Lage das
zu beurteilen was mich überrascht hat
ist dass Herr Kalla mehrfach gesagt hat
er möchte sich nicht an Spekulationen
beteiligen dass er aber dann doch immer
wieder zu Spekulation neigte also zu er
schilderte das Demonstrationsgeschehen
am Rande er sprach sehr eindeutig von
dem Anschlag und dann vielen sogar was
in der AFD relativ häufig passiert ja
die angeblichen Dienste die ihm
vielleicht irgendwie auch mit no chock
hätten vergiften wollen das hat mich
dann doch ein bisschen überrascht mhm ja
er hat eingangs gesagt er vertraut und
möchte sich an Spek nicht beteiligen
vertraut da vollkommen der
Staatsanwaltschaft gleichzeitig haben
wir erfahren dass es eine Abmahnung
gegeben hat oder erer eben wie er es
nennt juristischen Kontakt mit der
Staatsanwaltschaft ist das sind auch so
ein bisschen zweideutige Angaben und
dann würde ich gerne mit Ihnen noch mal
sprechen über das Wording also in der
Ankündigung der Pressekonferenz ging es
um einen Vorfall während dieser
Wahlkampfveranstaltung im Laufe der
Pressekonferenz hat Tino kopaller dann
selbst von einem Angriff und auch einem
Anschlag
gesprochen und die Frage ist das ist ja
eine Interpretation seinerseits ich habe
jedenfalls jetzt aus dieser
Pressekonferenz nicht schlüssig erfahren
dass das tatsächlich so war oder sehen
Sie das anders das sehe ich genauso wie
sie das auch sehen
wie gesagt ich habe diese wenigen Fakten
neu erfahren aber darüber hinaus wäre
ich jetzt noch weit D von entfernt zu
sagen dass mir die Fakten wie er sie
immer nannte jetzt wirklich einen
Anschlag oder einen Angriff bestätigen
im Gegenteil hat er noch mal gesagt dass
er in der Situation selber nichts
verspürt hat sondern erst nachdem ihm
schlecht geworden sei und zwar 7 bis 8
Minuten später habe er dann eben im
Beisein der BKA Beamten diesen Blutfleck
an seinem Oberarm und eine womöglicher
Einstichstelle gesehen mm
was bislang von der Staatsanwaltschaft
verlautet ist das das wurde ja auch
mehrfach genannt bislang zumindest gibt
es jetzt keine Zeichen oder hat man
keine Substanzen gefunden die auf eine
Vergiftung hindeuten ähm das ist er das
was er ja so ein bisschen unterstellt
oder als Grund für seine Symptome die er
aufgeführt hat äh ja immer wieder
anbringt das sind natürlich erstens
recht diffuse Symptome die die wir alle
wahrscheinlich kennen ne das das können
ganz ganz unterschiedliche Ursachen ähm
sein
ähm das ist das eine und
ähm dann geht es ja auch um die
ärztliche Schweigepflicht also er er
bringt jetzt sozusagen diese
diese Arztberichte nach oben die ja auch
in der Diagnose da bin ich mir auch gar
nicht so sicher
ist das eine wirkliche Diagnose eines
Arzt oder beruht das eigentlich auf
Angaben des Patienten das was da in
einen Arztbrief hineineschrieben wird
also das Büro Kalla hat ja am Freitag an
einige Medien offenbar diesen Arztbrief
verteilt und öffentlich gemacht damit
unter anderem an das ZDF und vorher
schon an die AFD na Junge Freiheit m die
Junge Freiheit hatte eben dann einfach
zitiert was dort drin stand das hat der
Herr Kalla in Teilen eben auch
vorgelesen
die Deutsche Presseagentur die hatte das
auch erhalten und die hatten daraufhin
noch mal Ingolstadt nachgefragt und
hatten genau die Frage die sie gerade
stellen wohl auch gestellt und haben
daraufhin die Antwort erhalten dass das
wor was dort notiert ist vor allem auf
den Angaben von henaller Fuße also das
hat sich auch die Deutsche Presseagentur
nicht aus gedacht diese Einschränkung
vielleicht ist das auch der Grund warum
Herr krupaller dann daraufhin in in
Dresden wie er sagt jetzt noch mal auf
eigene Faust diese Stichstelle hat
entnehmen und anschauen lassen mhm
letzte Frage ach so sie hatten gerade
noch gefragt zur ärstlichen
Schweigepflicht da waren wir glaube ich
noch nicht gerne
da wollte ich noch dazu sagen es war das
ganze fand natürlich irgendwie wenige
Tage vor der Landtagswahl in Bayern und
in hessenstadt das waren ja sehr
wichtige Wahlen auch ähm und das war
eben auch nicht zu trennen von den
angeblichen Gefährdungen von Frau Weidel
und dem Grund für die Absage ihres
wahlkampfsaustrittes in Bayern ähm
deshalb ist es glaube ich auch die
Aufgabe von Journalistinnen und
Journalisten nachzufragen Fragen zu
stellen und es ist auch die Aufgabe der
Staatsanwaltschaft ja nach den auch
Anschuldigung die aus dem AFD Lager kam
dass es sich um einen Anschlag gehandelt
habe ähm dem nachzugehen ähm und Fragen
von Journalistinnen und Journalisten zu
beantworten dann stelle ich jetzt noch
eine letzte ich würde gerne noch mal
eine Einschätzung von ihnen haben zu dem
Zeitpunkt dieser Pressekonferenz jetzt
von Tino kopaller denn die
Staatsanwaltschaft hat ja gesagt wir
haben auch noch mal nachgefragt und uns
erkundigt man könne im Laufe dieser
Woche mit einem Ergebnis rechnen das
hätte man ja nun jetzt auch noch
abwarten können dann hätte man sozusagen
ein offizielles Ergebnis
gehabt wie beurteilen Sie dass das Tino
kropaller jetzt ausgerechnet dann heute
sozusagen vorgeprescht ist
ja er wollte da ziemlich augenscheinlich
eben seine Sicht erstmal dahinstellen
ich weiß nicht warum er das gemacht hat
er er geht ja davon aus dass das Fakten
sind die man aneinanderlegen kann und
die für ihn zu einem eindeutigen Schluss
führen warum er das gemacht hat das
müssen sie glaube ich ein kopalla Fragen
alles klar ich danke Ihnen an der Stelle
kommen wir nicht mehr dazu Katja Riedel
vom WDR investigativ Journalistin vielen
Dank und wir schauen nach Brüssel denn
da treffen sich heute die NATO
Verteidigungsminister auch Boris
Pistorius der deutsche
Verteidigungsminister wird heute ab